imagínate que has encontrado un producto
realmente sorprendente que quieres ir a
vender a eeuu
ahora bien supongamos que este producto
también tiene que ver con la altura de
los hombres de eeuu por lo tanto creo
que va a servir encontrar la media de la
altura de todos los hombres de eeuu
entonces yo quiero la media de la altura
de todos los hombres en estados unidos
como el encuentro y bueno lo primero que
hay que preguntarse es a que media me
refiero si me refiero a la media
geométrica a la media aritmética
etcétera pero cuando uno habla en
general de media o de promedio estamos
pensando en la media aritmética entonces
supongamos que yo tengo un conjunto con
todos los hombres que hay en eeuu lo voy
a apuntar de este color y éste va a ser
toda la cantidad de hombres que tengo en
eeuu es un conjunto para ello sacar la
media de esta de las alturas de estos
hombres en eeuu podríamos pensar en ir a
medir a cada uno de los hombres de eeuu
a medir sus alturas uno por uno sumar
todas las alturas y dividirlas entre la
cantidad de hombres que hay en eeuu sin
embargo eso no suena muy factible suena
hasta casi imposible porque tenemos
aproximadamente 150 millones de hombres
en eeuu 1 tardaría una eternidad en ir a
medir a cada uno de los hombres en eeuu
además de que el tiempo imagínate que
muchos norteamericanos cambian de país
otros norteamericanos mueren algunos más
nacen entonces es tener la altura de
todos los 150 millones de
norteamericanos que hay aproximadamente
en un cierto tiempo es casi imposible no
suena nada lógico por lo tanto lo que se
me ocurre es no ir a medirlos a todos
solamente a medir una muestra de esa
cantidad de norteamericanos que hay
entonces supongamos que yo me tomo una
muestra de la cantidad de hombres
norteamericanos que existen y ojo es una
muestra aleatoria
es decir no voy a ir a preguntarles a
los jugadores de básquetbol de eeuu su
altura o en su dado caso a las personas
más chaparras de eeuu su altura lo que
me interesa es tener un combinado de
alturas me muestra es decir una muestra
aleatoria y bueno ya que yo tenga a mis
personas que van a estar en mi muestra a
cada una les voy a calcular la altura y
tal vez con esas alturas yo pueda
calcular el promedio de sus alturas es
decir la media de mi muestra y esa media
de mi muestra me puede decir algo que
tenga que ver con la media poblacional
es decir con la media de todas las
alturas de mi población y la afirmación
es la siguiente en efecto si nosotros
calculamos la media poblacional entonces
nos va a decir bastante de la media de
toda la población dicho en otras
palabras inferir conocimiento de la
muestra muchas veces te da conocimiento
de la población en este caso estamos
hablando de la media entonces vamos a
poner un ejemplo supongamos que nuestra
muestra es de hecho cualquier muestra
que ustedes tomen puede servirles pueden
tomar un mayor rango de confiabilidad si
toman 100 personas 150 personas es la
cantidad de hombres que ustedes quieran
tomar en su muestra sin embargo para no
hacerlo muy largo me voy
solamente 5 datos y estos datos se miden
en pies porque recuerden que los
norteamericanos miden su altura en pieza
recuerden que la muestra tiene que ser
aleatoria entonces supongamos que uno de
mis hombres mide seis puntos dos pies
el otro 5.5 pies el que sigue 5.75 aquí
me falta un 55 puntos 75 pies el que
sigue es 6.3 pies el cuarto y por último
el quinto mide 5.9 pies ahora la
pregunta es como saco yo la media de
estos cinco datos es decir la media
muestral pues es muy fácil voy a sumar
todos ellos y dividirlo entre la
cantidad de datos entonces con la
calculadora voy a poner 6.2 más 5.5 +
5.75 más 6.3 + 5.9 y esto es igual a
29.65 pies este es el valor de la suma
de mis alturas
ahora hay que dividir este valor entre
la cantidad de datos entonces 29.65
dividido entre 5 datos
5.93 pies por lo tanto ahora si mi media
muestral es 5.93 y ojo la media muestral
la ponen como una equis con un gorrito
encima es decir con una equis con una
barra encima esta de aquí va a ser mi
media muestral la media de mi muestra o
la media muestral y bueno en algunos
libros de textos le llaman a esta
operación que acabamos de hacer
estadística por lo tanto vamos a ponerlo
más vale que lo pongamos para que si
alguna vez lo ven así recuerden que esto
puede ser también llamado como la
estadística muy bien ahora la pregunta
sería qué pasa con esta media muestral
ya que vamos a obtener a comparación de
la media de toda la población bueno lo
primero que me preguntaría es cómo se
denota la media de la población y se
denota con una letra griega con la letra
griega muy entonces vamos a ponerlo
media de la población la llaman muy la
letra griega mod tome nota la media de
la muestra se denota con una equis con
una barra encima mientras que la media
de toda la población se denota con la
letra griega
y ya que andamos aumentando en conceptos
tanto mu como la equis con una barra
encima se les conoce como parámetros
entonces estos son parámetros ahora bien
hablemos de la media poblacional muchas
veces es muy fácil calcularla si tenemos
pocos individuos en nuestra población
pues entonces hacemos la media como
siempre hemos calculado sin embargo si
tenemos muchos individuos en nuestra
población no es nada sencillo calcular
la media de la población por lo tanto
tomamos una muestra como lo que hicimos
ahorita y hay que confiar en la media de
la muestra es decir en la media muestral
y bueno hasta ahorita hemos hablado de
un caso particular con 5 datos que pasa
si tenemos una población que tiene no sé
muchos pero muchos datos como 50
millones de datos y de esos 50 millones
de datos nosotros tomamos una muestra de
de datos la pregunta que les voy a hacer
es cómo le hacen los matemáticos para
escribir que van a sumar en de datos y
bueno para eso se utiliza la anotación
de x subíndice y que es x subíndice y
bueno supongamos que tenemos estos cinco
datos y seguimos trabajando con ellos
entonces el primer dato para llamarlos
de una manera matemática le ponemos x
subíndice uno el segundo dato x
subíndice 2 el tercer dato x wins de 3 y
así sucesivamente fíjense es como el
dato x subíndice 1 el dato 2 x 15 2 el
dato 3 x suben 3 de 3
el dato 4 x 2004 y x subíndice 5 y bueno
así podemos tener n datos podemos
seguirle x subíndice 6x subíndice 7
etcétera hasta x subíndice n y bueno
como se escribiría entonces que queremos
sacar la media de una muestra entonces
la media de una muestra es decir x con
un gorro encima es la suma ojo este
símbolo significa la suma de quién
voy a sumar todas las x subíndice y
desde y igual y donde empezamos
empezamos en 1 desde igual a 1 hasta
dónde vamos a parar supongamos que
tenemos n datos entonces es la suma
desde igual a uno hasta n donde
empezamos se pone abajo y donde
finalizamos se pone arriba y qué quiere
decir todo este símbolo a pues es la
suma de x 1 más x2 x 3 más todos todos
todos hasta x nx11 más x 2 x 3 más más
más más más hasta x n y bueno si
queremos sacar la media nos falta
dividir entre la cantidad de datos pero
si nuestra muestra tiene n datos
entonces habrá que dividir entre n en
este caso teníamos 5 y dividimos entre 5
en este caso tenemos n y hay que dividir
todo esto entre n entonces esta es la
forma matemática de poner la media de
una muestra es decir como la suma desde
igual a uno hasta ndx y todo esto
dividido entre n espero que no sea muy
abstracto esto sin embargo no se
preocupen n es
cantidad de datos que tenemos y tenemos
que sumar a todos los datos que ya les
hemos puesto el nombre de x 1 x 2 x 3 y
después dividirlo entre la cantidad de
datos que tenemos es decir entre n y
bueno sí ya entendimos esta anotación
que pasa o como podríamos escribir la
media de una población es decir muy a
pues bueno tenemos que tomar también una
suma de quien pues de todos los datos es
decir la suma de x y de donde donde a
pues empezamos en el primer dato desde
igual a 1 hasta donde hasta no puede ser
n minúscula porque en minúscula era los
datos de una población chiquita es decir
de una muestra entonces vamos a parar
hasta n mayúscula supongamos que tenemos
en mayúscula datos en toda mi población
y bueno si tenemos en mayúsculas datos
en toda mi población hay que dividirlo
entre n mayúscula es decir esto es lo
mismo que x1 más x2 x 3 más todos los
demás hasta más x en mayúscula y todo
esto dividido entre n datos y bueno esta
es una forma de escribir todo
estas sumas grandotas de una manera
reducida espero que no sea un concepto
muy abstracto para ti y date cuenta de
que esta forma de escribirlo es mucho
más sencilla que escribir todas las
sumas nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo